Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Wasif from Dhaka. Welcome.
Speaker 3: Hello. It's been a while. Thank you for
picking me. Protocol, I guess. Pleasure. Henry?
Speaker 1: Yes. From Bangladesh.
Speaker 3: Yes. Yes. Okay. So my
question is, you know, more or
less related to, you know, the
gun topic, I guess you could say the gun
control issue or whatever you may call it.
Sure. This is sort of I think, you know, like I
have heard this phrase, you know, mainly among
all these youngest Americans. I mean, even
Ben SHAPIRO went to, you know, let's say
what's his name? Well, Piers Morgan, Piers
Morgan's TV show. Right. And he basically,
you know, stated out this point to their point was
basically like this, that, you know, our ancestors
in Eastern Europe are in ashes because they didn't
have guns to protect their say. We need, you know,
less gun restrictions, basically. Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I've addressed that before.
It's crazy. I have addressed it. Yeah. So, yeah. I
mean, listen, I. Ben Shapiro's Jewish. I'm Jewish.
He has fallen for this talking point that
if the Jews had had guns, the Holocaust
wouldn't have happened. Historians have
looked at the claim. It's just the facts
aren't true and the conclusion isn't true.
Guns were not initially even banned. I mean,
there's so many reasons why it's historically
inaccurate, but I can assure you that handguns
and rifles would not have prevented the Holocaust.
Speaker 3: Obviously. I'm just I'm asking you
because I know you were Jewish, right? That's why,
you know, I could have asked this question to,
you know, let's say and, you know, let us doing,
you know, similar work as your, you know, leftist
podcast site. But I chose you specifically to ask
this question because I knew your background was
Jewish. Okay. Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Well, my answer has nothing to
the whole. I think the important thing
is my answer is just based on what
historians have written about it. And me being
Jewish doesn't doesn't change that. Okay. Well,
thank you for the call. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Earl Gump.
Speaker 1: All right, there goes.
Wasif great to hear from him.